ILYA GRIGORIK: Hello.
Welcome.
Today I would like to share some
tools, tips, and tricks
in Chrome Developer Tools that
will help you build better and
faster web apps.
These are tips that I find
useful, and I use every day.
And we're going to touch on a
little bit of everything,
networking, JavaScript
performance, rendering, and
other kind of deeper tools
within Chrome DevTools.
So without any further ado,
let's get right into it.
We're going to have two parts
to this presentation.
So in the first one, we'll
talk about the high-level
features available in
Chrome DevTools.
And these are the tools that
you'll be using every day on
your pages or on your apps
as you're building them.
And then part two will be a
little bit deeper, going into
how does Chrome DevTools work?
How can you extend it?
How can customize it and do
some really awesome stuff?
So I encourage you guys to
check out both videos.
But to start, you can follow
along by viewing these slides
on your own.
And in fact, I encourage you to
do so after you watch this,
because it's one thing to just
watch somebody do it and then
to try it yourself.
So grab the slides later, but
let's get right into it.
So first we have the Elements
and Console view which, of
course, everybody will
be familiar with.
You've used this every day.
And a couple of things that I've
actually just recently
discovered myself is that
you can drag and
drop elements in here.
And there's a couple of very
nifty features for debugging.
So, for example, if I right
click on this element here--
and I'm going to inspect
this element.
We our LI here.
Let me just scroll up a
little bit so we can
see what we're doing.
And we have this Delete
Me element.
So I can actually drag this up
and change its position, which
is quite nice.
And because we have this element
selected, we can also
do $0 to view the element
itself. so
very nice for debugging.
All of that's kind of neat.
But this is what really
interested me when I
discovered this.
So we have this element called
Delete Me, and we have the
Delete button.
And oftentimes you're doing some
sort of Ajax interactions
or building an app.
And you're trying to figure
out what's causing some
certain event, what's causing
a certain element to be
modified in the DOM.
And in fact, you can do
that very easily.
You can discover what's
happening by right clicking on
an element, going to Break On,
and in this case, I'm actually
going to remove the
element, so going
to say on-node removal.
But you can also do it on any
sub-tree modifications or
anything similar.
So I'll set a break
point in here.
And when I click Delete Me,
you can see that the page
actually paused.
It says, Pausing Debugger.
And it'll show us the specific
element or the JavaScript
file, the function that's
causing the action to occur.
So if I hit Continue, it'll
delete that element.
So nice and simple, very useful
if you're building
JavaScript apps or anything
that modifies the DOM.
And speaking of which, before
we get too far into the
specifics of the tools,
a couple of tips.
First of all, definitely check
out your settings.
There's a lot of very nice
features in there.
And some of those features don't
make sense to have on
all the time, but sometimes
they can be invaluable.
So, for example, I do a lot of
optimization of first-page
loads, so trying to figure out
how we can accelerate the
loading the page.
And for that, I find Disable
Cache as one of the most
useful features all the time.
Because I often wonder, did I
reload this page correctly?
Did I fetch that resource
out of the cache?
Because that could be
skewing the results.
So when you have that checked
on, it means that any time you
have the DevTools open, Chrome
will not use the cache.
It will always fetch
the resources
from the origin page.
Now, if you close your DevTools,
it'll continue using
your cache.
So this is actually something
you can keep on, and it'll
work just fine.
So don't worry about disabling
all your caches.
We'll talk about Show
Paint Rectangles.
This is an awesome feature, very
important for rendering
performance.
If you are building an app
that is Ajax heavy--
a lot of modifications
within the app--
logging XML HTTP requests
is actually very useful.
You can, of course, see the
outbound requests in your
network panel.
But if you have this enabled,
you will actually see Chrome
log the events, the HTTP
requests, into your console.
And it'll actually print the
object there so you can open
it up and look at some
of the parameters.
So your mileage will vary
based on what kind of
applications you're building
but may be
interesting to explore.
And then the last one that I
like to highlight, because
this bugged me for a little
while until I discovered this
option, is that Chrome tends to
reformat your CSS markup or
the colors into RGB
by default.
Whereas if you're using HEX,
if all of your code is
originally in HEX, you would
like to see it in HEX.
Well, you can tell it
to preserve it.
Or you can actually make it
switch into a different mode
like HSL, which allows you to
use the color picker right
within Chrome to get nice
changes done right within
Chrome DevTools if you're trying
to find a lighter shade
of color or something similar.
So moving right along,
network timeline.
This is the bread and
butter of a lot of
the work that I do.
So I spend a lot
of time in it.
And one of the things that I
know that happens to me is,
after awhile, there's a lot of
information hidden here, and
it just kind of gets
lost on you.
So I like to bring back the
attention on some of the
awesome features that
are hidden in here.
So, for example, we have-- if
you look at the Size column in
here, we have Size
and Content.
And maybe this is not the most
intuitive way to explain it,
but if you look at this, it
says that the size of this
page is 10 kilobytes, but the
content is 41 kilobytes.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that we've
transferred 10 kilobytes to
fetch this page.
But the actual resource is 41
kilobytes, which means that we
are actually using gzip.
So we've fetched 10 kilobytes.
That got expanded on a client
and all the rest.
And in fact, you can see that
this applies to virtually all
of the resources,
which is great.
It means that gzip is on.
We're using compression, which
is a very good optimization.
But then you scroll here to the
bottom, and you'll find
that we have our Google
Analytics snippet, and it only
fetches 35 bytes, or the content
is only 35 bytes.
But there's 855 bytes of HTTP
overhead, if you will.
And that also makes sense
because this is simply an
Analytics beacon.
So we're sending data to the
Google Analytics service.
It just returns a 204, and
there's nothing wrong here.
But very quickly, you can
diagnose if any resource is
not getting properly
compressed.
That's the place to find it.
The other and very similar
view that's worth paying
attention to is the
Time column.
So here we have, once again,
two elements--
Time and Latency.
So time is the total duration
to fetch that resource.
So for this specific page,
it took 1.18 seconds.
But the latency is the time that
it took to get the first
byte of that response.
So for whatever reason, we were
waiting for one second.
Maybe that's a new TCP
connection that needed to be
established.
So we needed to do
the negotiation
and hence the delay.
So you can see that, for
example, in this case we spent
most of the time waiting
on the network.
And then once the request got
fulfilled, it actually came
back very, very quickly to us.
Now, the last bit that I find
incredibly useful, but perhaps
is not the most intuitive, is
I'm going to flip to this page
here, just a random page.
And looking at this waterfall,
we get the timeline of how the
resources are loading.
But you can actually click on
the timeline and sort it by a
different metrics.
So, for example, we already
talked about
duration and latency.
So if I want to find out which
are the resources that were
queued the most or were waiting
the most for the
network to respond, I can
click on latency, and it
re-sorts all of the resources in
this timeline and shows you
that, hey, this photo file that
we were fetching, we were
waiting for 1.46 seconds.
There was some connection time,
SSL time, et cetera.
And then the actual resource
fetch was basically a no-op,
so very, very useful.
You can find very interesting
performance bottlenecks by
using this.
And likewise, we can re-sort
this by duration, which is the
total time.
So this is combined waiting
on the latency and
fetching the resource.
So, for example, this JOD file,
which we're fetching
from Twitter in this case, 357
milliseconds to do the DNS
look up, which is quite
a bit of time.
Then kind of a waterfall of
all the other metrics for
connection and receiving
and all the rest,
so very, very useful.
Let's go back.
Similarly in the same timeline,
we actually have two
very useful tips for figuring
out how the resources are
getting scheduled.
So when the server responds with
data-- so whether that's
an HTML file or JavaScript
or CSS file--
the document parser or the
browser picks it up and tries
to figure out what other
resources are required.
So the browser schedules
these resources.
And here we can actually show
you that some documents-- or
sorry, some resources are being
schedule by the document
parser and some by scripts.
Now, why is this interesting?
It's interesting because in
order for something to get
scheduled by a script, the
script needs to be downloaded.
It needs to be executed first.
And only then can the
browser fetch these
resources, which is fine.
But it hides a lot of
the information
away from the browser.
So in that case, the browser
can actually help you
accelerate these downloads.
If you just have the resources
directly in your HTML, the
browser can be actually very
smart about how to schedule
those and preemptively fetch
those resources to avoid
slowdowns on the page.
So it's very popular now to
use JavaScript loaders.
Those are great.
They can offer a lot
of great features.
But you're hiding some
of that information.
And we'll come back to
this in a second.
So after you look at the network
timeline closely, you
kind of drill into the specifics
of where am I
spending my time?
Is it the latency?
Am I blocking the server
and other things?
You start to observe patterns.
And it's actually quite
remarkable because after a
while, it doesn't even matter
what the specific page is you
are looking at.
You just see patterns where you
quickly figure out another
one and like, OK, I have a
blocking JavaScript file which
is doing a document
write which is
blocking something else.
So as an example, I have this
seemingly incredibly simple
example here where we're
fetching two resources, and
it's an HTML page.
And as you can see, now we
know how to read this.
It takes 1.5 seconds to fetch
this entire HTML page.
But the latency is very low.
It's 9 milliseconds, which
means that we send the
request, and we get a response
almost immediately.
Or at least we don't get
the full response.
We get some part of
the response.
So the server gave us some
data, but it's still
processing the rest.
And based on this data, because
we're scheduling the
style.css file, it means that
that data that got served
contained a reference
to this style sheet.
So that already tips off
the browser to go and
download this file.
But this file, the style sheet,
has a very different
performance profile.
So in here, you can see
that the opacity is
different on this line.
And this shows you that the
latency is high, which means
that we've sent the request, but
the server took one second
to generate the actual
response.
It didn't return any bytes.
And then at the very end, it
gave us that little bit of CSS
that we needed to render
this page.
So just by looking at this, you
can actually infer a lot
of what's happening on the
back-end and figure out how
you can optimize your pages.
So this also highlights another
property, which is
time to first byte, which means
that in this case, even
though the page itself was
taking 1.5 seconds, we were
able to flush some of the
content early and get the
browser to start downloading
these resources, which speeds
up the overall experience,
of course.
So I already covered some of
this, but the very high-level
overview is that the browser
tries to be your friend in the
sense that it tries to help
you build a fast web page.
And the network stack inside of
a modern browser tries to
do predictive loading
of resources and
all kinds of things.
So when you think about it, as
we push bytes to the browser,
it starts to tokenize those
files-- so for example, the
HTML file--
and figures out that, hey,
there's the style
sheet that I need.
And at that point, it can
actually schedule it onto the
network stack to fetch it, which
is exactly what we saw
in the previous slide.
Alternatively, if the parser
blocks for whatever reason--
so let's say we have a
JavaScript file which needs to
be downloaded--
well, you don't want to wait
because maybe there's a style
sheet right after it that
we could fetch.
So we have this thing called
the pre-load scanner which
kind of forges ahead.
And it doesn't even do
a deep parse of HTML.
Instead, it just looks for
things like images, style
sheets, and JavaScript.
And it then schedules those
resources ahead.
So that's also fairly good
in terms of performance.
And perhaps the slowest way to
schedule something and fetch
it from the network is to
construct the DOM, get the
JavaScript to executive, and
then JavaScript is the piece
that schedules the resources.
So we have a script that
schedules, let's say, an image
or another JavaScript
download.
So it's the lowest layer in the
stack here because, well,
it'll take the longest
in general.
So this is a trade-off that you
have if you're using, or
abusing even, the JavaScript
loaders.
So just keep that in mind.
Speaking of network, we also
have web socket integration.
So let me find this demo here.
We have a sample website
which has web sockets.
And it says Socket Open.
And in fact, if you look
down here, we have
the Web Socket tab.
So we click into that.
We see the actual request.
This is the web socket
connection.
We can click on this, and we get
the actual request headers
and the handshake and everything
that's associated.
But you can also click into
frames and see the actual
frames being exchanged between
the client and server.
So if I type in hello here,
you can see that this new
frame was sent--
hello--
the length and the time, so
very useful if you're
transferring ASCII text across
your web socket.
Of course, if you're
transferring binary data
across web sockets, this is
not going to be as useful.
But for many applications, this
is exactly what you need,
so very handy.
Another feature that I don't
think a lot of people know
about is the HAR format.
So the HAR format stands for
the HTTP Archive format.
And the way to think about it is
the HAR format captures all
of the data necessary to capture
exactly what you see
in the network waterfall, so
all of the metadata that's
happening here.
And it's not only just the
visible stuff that we see
here, but we can, of course,
also click into any one of
these files and see all kinds
of other information.
So to capture this file, you can
right click, and you have
two options.
You can save these specific
metadata for one resource, so,
for example, a CSS file,
or for the entire page.
So I'm going to do this.
I'm going to click on
Save All as HAR.
And I'm just going
to download it.
And it gives me this
.HAR File.
And this is just a JSON file,
which contains all of the
information that is embedded
in this file.
Now, why would I want this
in this timeline?
So often, I'll be debugging
a page, and I find
some sort of a problem.
And I'll mark it up in a
screenshot, send it to my
buddy, and say like, hey,
I found a problem.
We need to fix this.
And then he comes back and says,
well, that's cool, but
I'm missing this metadata.
So can you give me
more information?
And, of course, by that
time I've closed the
tab, so that's it.
It's over.
With HAR files, you have all of
the metadata that you could
attach to a bug report or
send to somebody else.
Very useful stuff.
So for example, here's
a web app.
It looks like Chrome
Developer Tools.
That's because it
basically is.
Somebody just extracted the code
out of Chrome Developer
Tools and made it
as a web page.
And what I can do is I can
take the HAR file we just
saved, drag it in here,
and look at that.
We have the entire waterfall
available to us.
And in fact, you can even click
into this file, and
there's all of that
same metadata.
So now when somebody sends you
this HAR file, you can just
pop in here, look at
all of the data.
You have the full fidelity.
You don't need to sacrifice on
anything, which I think is
quite, quite awesome.
And not only that, but there's
a ton of other tools that you
could use once you have these
HAR files to build better
dashboards, better
integrations.
You can feed them automatically
into tools like
YSlow to run performance reports
and other things.
So Peter and myself actually
recorded an entire one-hour
episode on the myriad of
different things that you can
do with a HAR file.
So I definitely recommend that
you guys check it out.
It's a very, very powerful tool,
and there's a lot of
open source projects that are
doing amazing stuff with it.
So that's a lot about
the network, right?
And once we fetch those
resources, we actually need to
display the page layout, the
page, and provide a good
experience once the user is
interacting with the page.
And the way to think about it is
there are kind of two broad
components.
There is the DOM tree, which is
what gets constructed out
of your HTML, and then there's
all the rendering information
or the CSS object model.
And those two things have to
come together in order to
create the render tree, which
is ultimately what gets
outputted to the screen,
or painted to the
screen, if you will.
And the thing to keep in mind
is that, generally speaking,
the rule of thumb is the further
apart you can keep
these things--
if your DOM object model
JavaScript is querying your
CSS all the time, that's going
to be synchronizing these
basically concurrent
data structures.
And any time you synchronize
anything, performance
goes out the door.
So that's kind of a
high-level tip.
But what are we after?
We're after a smooth
experience, right?
We want 60 frames per second
on our web pages.
And if at this point you're
asking yourself
60 frames per second?
I'm not trying to build
a game here.
I'm just trying to scroll
on a page like it's
nothing crazy, right?
Well, not so fast.
It turns out you can actually
do a lot of things that can
compromise on the general
performance.
So here's an example
that I like to use.
We have a couple of different
tools within Chrome DevTools
that can really help you
highlight or discover if you
have an issue in this respect.
So I'm going to go into Google+,
and I'm going to
enable Show Paint Rectangles.
So this is one of these options
that you don't want to
have on all the time, but very
useful when you need it.
So I'm going to click
on this, make this
a little bit smaller.
And now as I hover over
different elements, you see a
little box around all the
different elements.
And what this box tells you is
these are the elements that
are being repainted.
So the box shows you the
specific part of the screen
that needs to be repainted.
And generally speaking, the
smaller the area that you need
to repaint, the better, the less
work that the CPU and the
GPU and the browser has to do.
So hovering just over one
link highlights that.
But if you pay attention, in
some cases, we are actually
highlighting not only--
so in this case, we have this
box, but sometimes this entire
area is outlined.
So that means that on certain
interactions, this entire box
needs to be repainted, which
is probably not the best
experience.
Now, I haven't looked
in as to why.
Maybe there's a good reason
for why that needs to be
repainted in this case.
But generally speaking, this is
kind of a tip off to say,
hey, perhaps we shouldn't be
repainting the chat area every
single time that we hover over
a link, so very handy.
So we can disable that and
go back into here.
That tells you which areas get
repainted, which helps you
catch certain problems.
Or sometimes, you re-flow a
style on some other component
of the page that you didn't
even expect, and you're
rendering a lot of stuff that
you didn't need to.
But you can go even a
little bit deeper.
And you can go into our Frames
view, which we'll see in a
second, and it will highlight
how much time you're spending
on painting each frame.
So if we do our very basic math,
we have one second, and
we want to have 60 frames
per second.
That amounts to about 16
milliseconds per frame.
So that means you have a budget
of 16 milliseconds.
Now, Chrome itself has to do
some work to paint the screen.
So, generally speaking, let's
say we want to stay within 10
milliseconds.
And this is exactly what this
Frame view is showing you.
So each section here is
a specific frame.
And this is the amount
of time that it took
to paint each frame.
So if we stay under
this line--
and we'll see a better
example in a second--
that means that we're well
within our budget of 16
milliseconds.
But every once in awhile, we get
these frames which take a
lot longer.
And this causes a
skipped frame.
So why is that an issue?
Well, I have this very
simple example here.
When I click on this, this line
here is just showing you
the delay between a timer
firing on this page.
So, generally speaking, we want
this to be flat, which
means that it's firing on
a periodic interval.
There's no delays.
Everything's good, right?
And when I click on this button
right here, nothing
really happens because this
button kicks off about 5
milliseconds of work.
And as you would expect, we have
16 milliseconds during
which we need to finish
all of our work.
So you wouldn't expect anything
to happen, which is
exactly the way you want it.
Now, if I do the same thing and
I click on Skip 3, which
stands for skip three frames,
so about 50 milliseconds,
watch what happens.
All of a sudden, the timer
gets this major delay.
And that's because
we're literally
skipping three frames.
And maybe it's a little bit
hard to see, but in our
animation here, there's
a little bit of delay.
And to see it really show up,
we can click on skip 10.
And all of sudden, the entire
animation pauses, right?
So we have our JavaScript
running the animation.
And we're doing work in the
background, or we're kicking
off work when we click
on this button.
And that really causes this
jenk, which is not a good
experience.
So, couple of tips there.
If you do have work that needs
to be done for a good chunk of
work that doesn't fit into a
single frame, two things you
could think about.
One is to push it into
a web worker.
And the second is perhaps
even to split it.
So instead of doing one piece
of work over, let's say, 100
milliseconds, perhaps you can
split it into five chunks of
20 milliseconds.
And what that will allow you
to do is then allow the
browser to inject some frames
such that the animation
doesn't stop.
So you're still doing your
work, but you're kind of
piecing it together while
the browser is painting.
So that in itself
could be useful.
Let's look at this
next example.
This is an example that we had
at Google I/O. So this is a
very simple page.
As you scroll down, we're
just moving the Chrome
logos up and down.
So, let's opened DevTools.
We're gonna go into Timeline,
Frame view, and we're gonna
hit Record.
And we're just going to scroll,
so nothing too bad.
Now let's add some costly
effects, try scrolling again.
Ooh, look at that.
All of a sudden, the frames
are taking much longer.
And now I'm going to add some
on-scroll events, and boy, it
really gets bad.
So this is our original
experience here.
We can drill in on one
of these frames.
Let's actually pick even--
there we go.
So you can see that this one
frame-- so we have three
frames that we're
looking at here.
Each one of these was taking
approximately 100
milliseconds.
So, correspondingly, the page
was scrolling much slower.
And that's because we have
a couple different things
happening here.
First, we have this paint
happening, which-- so we're
updating the entire screen.
And we know that it's the entire
screen because you can
actually see the dimensions.
So this is literally the full
screen, and it's taking 15
milliseconds just to paint
this entire area.
So this is basically
our budget.
So that's a problem.
But not only that.
We also have this JavaScript
callback, so the on-scroll
event that gets fired.
And if we expand this, you can
see that, boy, we have a ton
of different style
recalculations.
So, of course, this is
a demo showing you a
pathological example.
But unfortunately, this is
something that happens very
frequently in the
wild as well.
So definitely check out the
Frames view, very handy to
help you debug and find problems
on your site in terms
of overall experience to improve
your experience.
And one last comment I'll make
about this is ideally you're
running at 60 frames
per second,
everything is nice and smooth.
But if you can't--
and that's OK--
try to run at a consistent
frame rate.
Maybe that's 30.
Maybe that's even 15 or lower.
But it's better to be consistent
than to jump up and
down all the time.
We're very good at detecting
changes in that respect.
So users will notice that.
So stay consistent, try to do
60 milliseconds where--
60 milliseconds.
The other tip I have
here is similar
to the network timeline.
You can actually export
this data.
And once again, you can
attach it to a ticket.
You can send it to
somebody else.
You can save it for analysis
for later, any
one of those things.
And not only that, but
you can also import
this data into DevTools.
So in the network view, we
use an external tool to
view the HAR file.
Here you can import that same
JSON right into DevTools and
reconstruct this entire
experience, so once again
very, very useful.
And if you look at the JSON file
that gets emitted, it is
incredibly data rich.
So it has all the information
about which JavaScript file is
executing, which lines, which
functions, what was the heap
size before, what was
the heap size after,
all kinds of stuff.
So even outside of DevTools,
that data could be used to
generate other reports or build
other interesting tools,
so definitely interesting
to explore.
On that note, let's move
into JavaScript.
So lots and lots of pages
are using lots
of JavaScript nowadays.
And a common problem, especially
for long-lived apps
that stay open for awhile, is
memory leaks, where you
allocate objects, and for
whatever reason, they stick
around, and they're not getting
garbage collected.
So, one tip that I have for you
guys is to use the Heaps
Snapshots view.
So let's take a look
at an example here.
You can find this example
on our Chrome Developers
documentation, but what I'm
going to do here is I'm going
to go into Profiles,
and I'm going to
take a heaps snapshot.
So I haven't done anything.
This is just a fresh page.
And it's going to capture
a snapshot.
And in here, it just shows you
all of the objects there are
currently allocated.
Nothing interesting happened.
Now, what we're going to do
is we're going to run this
snippet of code, and this
snippet of code just is going
to create a whole bunch
of item objects.
So you can take a look at this
JavaScript later, but
effectively, that's
all we're doing.
We're going to allocate a bunch
of objects and delete
some, except that we're
going to forget to
delete some of them.
So let's click on this
Action button.
We just allocated objects.
And we're going to take
another snapshot.
So let's go back, click
Start again, and
now we have two snapshots.
So, of course, once again, we
can drill into the snapshot
and look at the heap,
which is nice.
But ideally we want to see a
diff between these two states.
And that's exactly what
we can do here.
We can click on Comparisons.
And we can compare it
to snapshot one.
So we're comparing two to one.
And guess what?
You can see that the difference
is that between
these two runs, we allocated
over 10,000 objects.
We deleted 9,000, but
we forgot 1,000.
So 1,000 objects kind
of stuck around.
And you can expand that,
and you can see all
of these guys here.
So that's our memory leak.
So we just ran a diff between
the two different heaps, which
is very nice, very handy
for catching these.
Of course, you can also watch
your memory usage in the
timeline as you're
recording it.
But this is a very handy way
of finding the difference.
So let's go back.
You can also do similar things
for constructing DOM objects.
So oftentimes, maybe a
templating engine or maybe
your own code is creating some
sort of an HTML or a DOM
sub-tree, which then
gets misplaced.
You forget to delete it.
Or maybe you discard it, and
you don't deallocate it or
don't de-reference it.
And it's going to
stick around.
It's going to occupy
your memory.
So similar to what we did just
previously with JavaScript,
you can identify that via
the same process, so
definitely check it.
Getting to the audits.
So the Audit panel
has a couple of
very interesting features.
First of all, you can run an
audit to get a sense for what
are the kind of easy pickings
on this page to improve its
performance.
So let me go back to
this page here.
I'll go into Audits.
And we have a couple of built
an audits, right?
There's a network
and web page.
But really, the power of this
tool is in the fact that you
can easily extend it and
customize it, which is
something we're going to
talk about in the next
part of this video.
But let's run this
report here.
You can see that it's giving
me a couple of suggestions.
It's saying that, hey, you have
some resources which are
not being cached.
So perhaps that's something
you can fix.
Some cookie, image dimensions.
The one elective highlight
here is the
Remove Unused CSS Rules.
So if I expand this, it tells
me that, hey, you've
downloaded a bunch of CSS
to render this page.
But in fact, 78% of it is not
being used on this page.
Wow!
So, specifically on this
one file, we have 5
kilobytes of CSS.
54% is not being used.
And not only that, you can also
expand it and see the
specific selectors that are
embedded in that CSS file that
are not being used.
So if you're really trying
to tune your first-load
performance, perhaps you
can actually separate
these files, right?
Sometimes it's nice to have one
file which contains the
CSS for all your pages.
But sometimes, it does make
sense to split them apart and
use them as such, so
very handy tool.
And for a deeper look at your
page, I'd actually encourage
you guys to install an extension
from the Chrome
Store, which is PageSpeed
Insights.
So once you install
the extension,
you'll find a new tab.
And let me go to the
CNN example here.
I actually just ran
this report.
So I'm using PageSpeed, I hit
Run, and it analyzed the page.
It downloaded all the resources
and then did a whole
bunch of things.
And it's giving me a number
of recommendations.
So you can see that we
have high-priority,
medium-priority, and
low-priority recommendations
for how we could improve the
performance of this page, so
combine images, optimize
images.
I'll show you one--
optimize images.
So we found that by running this
extension that we could
reduce the size of this page
by 113 kilobytes, which is
quite significant.
So that's 31%.
And not only that, but we're
showing you the specific
images and how much you could
save if you used a better
compression technique, or
maybe you need to strip
metadata and other things.
So, one tip that I have is--
I don't think a lot of
people realize this.
We actually also give you
the optimized version.
So not only do we highlight what
was the image that could
have been optimized, we also
try to optimize it and give
you this version.
So I can click on See Optimized
Content here, and
here's the optimized file.
You can actually just save this
directly to your access
folder, and just replace
the original file,
and there you go--
optimization done.
So here's your image
optimization
built into Chrome DevTools.
And lots of other tips, I
should say, within the
Insights extension.
And there's a lot of very good
documentation as well.
So if some of the
recommendations don't actually
make sense, you can click on
Learn More, and we have
extensive documentation on why
it makes sense, when it
doesn't make sense to do that.
Not every optimization is
applicable to your case.
So check that out.
And with that, we're going
to wrap up with part one.
So in the next section, we're
going to go a little bit
deeper into DevTools itself,
how we can extend it, and
other cool things that
we can do with it.
Thanks.